now your hair looks like it could
[ __ ] beat the Quran virus hi could
you look like dart and if people want to
get some positivity [ __ ] carry a
sword I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do with my hair
either my girl asked me last night I was
taking a nap I popped up and she's like
well you look [ __ ] crazy I'm like
alright cool cuz I usually wear a hat
around the house and then she goes hold
on I know what you know I tried what you
know when you're kind of groggy wake up
and watches what's your plan with your
hair like I don't what I don't know well
I get to Bradley Cooper I don't know I
get a Bradley Cooper status I don't know
your well your d'Artagnan bring up
d'Artagnan you want about us cute tears
hey there you are
I wish I wish I see a straight dude all
I've ever wanted all I've ever wanted if
you really boiled down Brian Cowell
muscles in long hair that's all I've
ever wanted
all I've ever was was muscles long hair
and long hair that [ __ ] in your mouth
oh no that part hold on no I want to be
as honest Monday I want to say I want to
be a thick boy this way we're the
sweatshirt and I want to be I want to be
a little thick I want to be like dude
you're [ __ ] cow on this think like an
obese Gallants Callens [ __ ] sturdy
right like his legs you see is like I
want to be that guy no and then I want
thick black hair and I want skin the
tans not skinned do you want to you want
to be me well I do but we talked a
little bit about my disappointment in
your legs in your butt right we talked
about that and that's fair right is that
fair I guess no I no big deal and also I
have problem with your calves now listen
hold on I know that you have speed and I
know that people with small calves have
speed you'll have at a fast twitch yeah
I would like I would like a more robust
calf on you that's not for me to say
enough to build you know what is dude
huh I wish you had good hair and [ __ ]
muscle it's not gonna happen k and I
wish you weren't 90% gay but it's not
gonna have yeah I don't can I finish my
point so now is your teeth or a straight
not gonna help can I finish my point
listen it's [ __ ] this Monday so let me
just let me just say a couple things
when I see you I thought it was honest
Monday it's [ __ ] it's my holidays
Monday well it's on estate Monday
because because the world's coming to an
end so let's get it out there Brian came
in panicking let's just let the family
back see me panicking yeah my back
seized up but I'm panicking for other
people not me now listen know you're
kind of talking about yourself
[ __ ] hunker down I can bear down now
you here's what I do I see your
shoulders I see your hair I go [ __ ]
great then I see your legs I go [ __ ]
this right nassim I think you like oh
god well if you don't like what we're
doing here dude you should be text and I
know that's what you should be doing
yeah I'm just looking to see if I was
getting it you know I'm in a fight right
now with somebody that's oh he came a
little salty - yeah with a [ __ ]
contractor who's not doing a good job I
got to learn patience I'm a 53 year old
man who doesn't have patience okay I'm
glad Shepard of it I got anger issues
but you know what you know what I go
dark and now you're not gonna like this
and I don't like this but you paid these
[ __ ] yeah Papa you know I've had one
five houses now I never pay up for I pay
half up front right if the job's done
expectations' the other half when I did
you ain't get another half we're
installments here's the problem
what Papa was being stolen from oh yeah
and you know you can make a legal issue
but I'm not because well then you got
lawyer fee and those people already
don't have money and also what you'll
assume for us oh yeah and it's just it's
Dodge Ram you get you get you get
basically robbed in one way or another
and it is what it is and you just gotta
eat a dick and go mmm
learn from it next time here's what you
do you you get what you paid for and
when you go when you don't do your due
diligence with somebody and you just
think that they did this some people do
really well in one area of their life
and you think they're gonna do well on
something that's way more complicated
like building or remodeling there's so
much or or dealing with your finances we
learn the hard way as well by our
correct sir he's learning the hard now
now we're a little bit excused there
because we came highly recommended
[Laughter]
that's you but but wait I want you to
tell me what was going on with me and
you what do you mean the financial
people well hold on hold on for a second
I'll get back but I want you to that
help
the business for 20 years and I know
other actors got a lot of money
recommend alright real famous star good
friend of ours like you got to go with
this guy we've been with her for 25
years I was like all right went to him
seemed like fine and dandy sure he
looked identical the guy without the
hair from Joe exotic whatever yeah but
did that didn't work out then it turns
out that there was I had an ATM card
that I was using as an ATM card well
problem was and I both connect that
account it's a business account it's the
fire one hit account let's put all my
stuff on there yeah sold Brendan Harris
half is Tesla right what boyfriend in
here dumb horses yeah I'm gonna go for a
ride Wow hey man take it easy Bob this
really steep brotherbrother house
brother brother house brother brother
what brother Monday Wednesday Fridays
Papa needs it brother
I paid for half of it okay brother you
know it comes and goes right comes and
goes
Rhona comes karana coves stealing the
money from he comes and goes only for
like two years brothers Boyer five years
four years it's forty five years four
years brother hey you know what's great
I think we can take a learning less from
this what did I do about it right what
do we do about it nothing nothing well
we're all paid up it's fine but still it
was B but again I don't care now we're
good brother brothers huh cuz brother
we're brothers her brothers what's mine
is yours
you know to me one of your kids might
look more like me who gives a [ __ ] I
don't know you know I'm saying it
doesn't matter it is what it is we share
let me move in during Khurana let me
move in can't dude all right dose for
chicken during outbreak no this is from
the New York City Health Department in
Jack they're giving you tips on if you
want to have sex
these are a bunch of little tips here so
it's been found in feces of the people
who are infected with the virus but not
yet not a weight and I stay away from
poo but now you hadn't semen or vaginal
fluid mmm good there's some more stuff
wash your hands there's something about
[ __ ] to wash sex toys I don't know if
[ __ ] zebra hell yeah
I always gonna say I'm offerings ever
100% Roberge said that one time he goes
he goes my yep you guys you stick your
tongue in a girl's ass he gets shot on
so [ __ ] it I was like I was like how
saying their I was like yeah it's so
like I felt like a [ __ ] made me feel
like he was right in my face because you
get [ __ ] on you've met it's so [ __ ]
what house are okay it made me feel like
Taylor Swift yeah I felt like a [ __ ] I
was like yeah so what I don't I'm not a
big Rimmer it's not a big Rimmer so have
sex with the people close to you don't
have to above the rhythm of sex with
people outside in a movie I'm happy with
the mouth and the other thing mm-hmm
yeah just a couple of tips there New
York really need to put that out really
does do me a lot of babies coming yeah
we're on a Boomer our divorces and
babies ya know offensively saying karate
oh oh good I think I said god I should
have said cut up their proper Asian I
don't know I don't know true so this is
my problem when I watch the we're
already getting into it watch the news
and we recording good we're live don't
tell me that when you hear someone on go
uh they're like a local la news and they
are doing a live report from somewhere
and then they're like well this is Maria
Gonzalez from my from Pomona and then I
go okay now I get it and but then I go
but what and then people say well it's
it's proper to do it that way but then I
go what region of either of of Central
America or Mexico or Spain Contino what
where does that mean that when someone
says I would like some chow mein that I
have to say jump in
as a white dude okay really like so
typical to ask that right you are you
are white obviously I mean I just you
have an exotic sort of your hair tensed
there's an up run
oh there's and your body looks your body
looks african-american racist it's
racist Wednesdays Brian no hold on he
looks athletic and muscular here's the
interesting part - is American Samoa
eNOS is diabetic wanna touch tattoos
right just under the head just right up
on the edge you know the war tattoos on
their ass oh my god now that after you
hit about 50 51 you just start to age
quicker I swear to God the difference
between 50 and like 53 where like this
trainer who's been around forever and I
said my fingers don't be sprinting and
stuff your tendons are you know your or
if T I was like I noticed that I noticed
that my [ __ ] calves of my tendons
hurt more than 50 or dollars to be
sprinting right Zoe told you yeah why
would you spread I don't know who told
you not to sprint I'm telling him now
you should spring 43 cuz like so like
DJs on scum I hated squatting right yeah
and I was like I hate squats and then
I'm like I'm not good at them but you
didn't call getting old I did a lot of
squatting it you did the same thing and
then I was like you know what I'm just
gonna squat every day and I'm and then
I'm gonna deadlift every other day yeah
I'm just gonna start and cuz I couldn't
my back was bad and I couldn't deadlift
45 pounds and I couldn't deadlift the
bar and then I was like screw it I'm
doing it every day and tell I don't even
think about it and I stopped running as
well I was like oh it's hard on your
body and then I was like no I'm just
gonna do it and and everybody gets
strong when you do that so now I can
deadlift more than I did in college
practically intraday then I well thank
you for asking
I've wrapped with like 315 and then I
can go up to I can get up to like four
but I don't do this a lot of way ever oh
sure you were do with the trap are you
doing the straight bar straight bar no
again he'll do 400 right now four reps
and that's his warm-up for I'm not
joking for deadlifting oh that's that's
a lot he laughs at that
oh no I watched him do ready I'm just
let it warm up with 400 you ready I'm
ready for this I saw this with my own
eyes ready for this yeah 550 550 500 500
550 ready yeah he did tense ten reps
hold on you did 10 reps 550 now ready
he didn't said ten sets he did a hundred
reps with 550 pounds
Joel deadlift and he did it lifting
objects now it doesn't help
oh my god I mean his brother told me
that when Brennan was really dead
lifting when he was like dead lifting
over 700 pounds the bar would Bend he
was bending the bars zero and they were
mad at Brennan because he was bending
the bars
he's there's as your own amazin ruining
bars Oren Landau said there's strong and
then there's Brennan shop yeah that's
that's that's a god-given it's a weird
that's why you should believe in God
it's a weird he's a piece of [ __ ] and he
just thinks that that wasn't god-given
been working how many of your how many
of your MMA friends like that big the
great athletes yeah how many could do
that I don't know
let's go with zero let's go with zero
did a Turkish get up with the full
barbell with 155 pounds a Turkish getup
just got up just stood up with it out
like holding it like that right you call
him do this yeah there's business video
this is this video above this video I
also saw him do 30 pull-ups when he was
there with Tim Tebow 15 no big deal
hey Joey Tebow do when
thirty I would beat him impulses he
would beat me anything legs yeah he was
so his legs are so and I'd said to Tim I
go Brennan stronger than you because
he's too competitive huh
I mean when it cost some legs not a
chance
I'll give him that helper by eight beat
him though you beat her an upper body
yeah pull up silly yeah well I met him
once and I couldn't believe how big he
was
yeah what do you think you mean Jesus
Gronk is smaller than him he's a big
rocks not like Tim Tims afraid do grunts
a freak Atlantica Bronx yeah I mean
obviously Tim's like his I mean his work
out to Mike Hoadley
well you know but I see like iris worker
I've ever met my life whether it's UFC
NFL DISA nobody's more discipline than
Tim Tebow no to the keto diet oh my god
dude you've never got mad at you he's
like try he's like he's like how much
you know much better you could be it's
like I did you know he's easy he's a
what would he do if he saw us oh he's
never had a drink in his life I don't
think right no he did once I think what
maybe once I I don't know yeah that dude
you know he's he's the real deal
he's a see the real deal great a nice
man I love him you just got made give
that to you as it's a gift
it's a gift